[Musique]
des contes dansés et chantés aux rythmes
du gwoka à la médiathèque jean rousselot
deux associations saint-quentinoise ont
fait découvrir les antilles tradition
danser et culinaires pour célébrer le
compte aux antilles on est beaucoup dans
l'oralité et
transmet beaucoup de générations en
générations à travers le conte et qui
dit content dit musique qui dit musique
dit instruments chez nous et tout cela
se mêlent se mélange il ya des comptes
ou les autres le contest on raconte
l'histoire du danseur l'histoire il ya
beaucoup de choses qui sont fermes
musique
pour cette 19ème édition de la fête du
conte les médiathèques emmène les
lecteurs en voyage arrive trip qui a
fait étape à guyancourt pour une escale
dans les îles
on s'est dit que au mois de janvier
février un petit peu de soleil dans nos
médiathèque ça ferait pas de mal et donc
donc c'était relativement facile et puis
c'est vrai aussi
l'idée c'était aussi de travailler avec
des avec des associations du territoire
les médiathèques vous conte des
histoires jusqu'au samedi 1er février